ja ich möchte heute eine partei
kritisieren von der es ganz gerne heißt
dass wir hier im hause springer zum netz
wir sind nämlich die fdp glück gehabt
die fdp
ich finde dass die fdp sich sehr viel
klarer sehr viel entschiedener dafür
einsetzen müsste dass wir in deutschland
einen echten freiheitstag bekommen ob
der film der heißt oder nicht ist mir
eigentlich relativ egal und sich im
ausland umschauen ein land nach dem
anderen wie dominosteine fallen die ja
gerade passiert wirklich sämtliche
kroner beschränkung 1 in deutschland
dagegen nicht kanntest du panik aus weil
am 19 märz das ist fast einen monat hin
noch die korona maßnahmen auslaufen die
übrigens dann auch noch zu den
strengsten der welt gehören
die ampel koalition diskutiert gerade
allen ernstes über diesen sogenannten
basisschutz unter dem sich dann
maßnahmen von der massen pflicht über
die abstandsgebot bis hin zu 2g und 3g
verbergen sollen die auch weiterhin
möglich sein sollen dass es so ziemlich
genau die kugel arbeit und leben da
sieht man bei dem vorher nachher
vergleich wahrscheinlich gar keinen
unterschied wenn man die fotos vom 18
und die fotos vom 22 märz vergleicht mir
kommt das alles ein bisschen vor wie
dieses seltsame steht was man hier in
geschäften sieht da steht ja immer drauf
wir mögen sie mit abstand am liebsten
und daran hat man sich irgendwie
eingerichtet habe ich das gefühl in
deutschland das klingt harmlos erst mal
abstand masken das ist aber sehr
gefährlich in einem rechtsstaat und will
man diese maßnahmen einmal entkoppelt
von einer akuten notlage die längst
nicht mehr gegeben ist darüber herrscht
einigkeit es gibt keine akute
notsituation in krankenhäusern solche
maßnahmen rechtfertigen könnte dann
schafft man enorm dann hat man nach der
neuen norm gesetzt und das darf nicht
passieren die fdp ist eine partei die
hat lässt es ja nicht auch das nicht
zuletzt deswegen so gut abgeschnitten
weil viele bürger vor allem auch viele
junge bürger das gefühl hatten dass die
vermutung für die freiheit
abgelöst worden ist in der pandemie
durch eine vermutung für die sicherheit
jetzt hat die fdp die freiheit im namen
das ist der erste buchstabe dieser
partei und trotzdem zögert sie sich klar
zu positionieren also ich nehme einzelne
stimmen war aus der fraktion und auch
aus den ländern aber christian lindner
und marco buschmann halten sich wer
vornehm zurück mit deutlichen ansagen
und dann finden wir auch wirklich alle
kokona maßnahmen teilen dabei wäre es
ihre aufgabe
darauf zu achten dass die einzige rote
linie die der rechtsstaat der
demokratische rechtsstaat wirklich kennt
respektiert wird nämlich das grundgesetz
die fdp muss jetzt zeigen warum sie
gewählt worden ist wofür sie gewählt
worden ist ich denke für faule
kompromisse braucht man keine fdp das
kann eine große koalition besser ja ich
meine das ist die ballade der politik
die man in allen ländern betrachten kann
das halte parteien im wahlkampf
großartigen programme vertreten und ihre
ideale
preisen und kaum sitzt man da nach
seinen bequemen ministersessel dann
verändert sich dann der mensch mit dem
foto und mit der wo gebetteten
ministerialen existenz und ich kann das
ich beobachte dass etwas distanz muss
sagen fast schon wieder bewundernswert
die komplexität und das wort chaos zu
vermeiden der korona maßnahmen in
deutschland da kommt ja ich glaube da
kommt ja selbst herr lauterbach und wir
völlig die übersicht verloren
deshalb beschließen
wichtig ist diese nur schrei nach
freiheit kann ich sehr gut nachempfinden
da kann ich euch nur sagen er kommt doch
mal ab und so in die schweiz nützt die
gelegenheit wahr zu einem kleinen
abstecher vielleicht auch mal ein
historiker seminar viele
vereine und russland der kommt aus
österreich durch gerichte zeit ist noch
die neue versicherung die deutschen
wüssten ja schon wie es geht nein kommt
in die schweiz wir haben die maßnahmen
danke erbittertem widerstand natürlich
der medien und auch in der direkten
demokratie das vielleicht auch der
letzte punkt das merkt man natürlich
dass in der schweiz aufgrund unseres
institutionellen modells der widerstand
gegen die maßnahmen viel größer war
warum hat man schon vor einem monat
gesagt die pandemie ist vorbei in
deutschland können sie auch nur alle
vier jahre wählen dazwischen hat die
regierung größere freiheiten und deshalb
haben sie auch ein bisschen größere
mühelos zu lassen denn macht ist
natürlich auch verführerisch macht führt
dazu dass sie die politiker nicht
loslassen aber diese sendung hat sich
große verdienste erworben hier ein
bisschen
kritisch dagegen zu halten und wenn es
dann einen frieden day gibt peter
nießing möglicherweise noch den
freiheits oder der bild -zeitung
umgehängt bekommen weil julia maßgeblich
verantwortlich bist aber treffe man
verstehe ich das argument nicht gar
nicht ja also das ist machtbewusstsein
werden soll der der fdp der saturierten
fdp-minister das leuchtet mir nicht ein
das macht bewusst denn einer liberalen
partei müsste doch gerade die chance
wittern sich jetzt zu positionieren denn
sonst prophezeie ich ist die fdp bei der
nächsten bundestagswahl wieder wer weiß
wie viel weiter unten wir erinnern uns
vor zwei wochen wenn sie draußen und
wenn die wähler der fdp die werden sich
sehr genau anschauen was da jetzt
passiert werden sich noch merken
deswegen denke ich also machtinstinkt
würde doch eher nahe liegen dass man die
chance ergreift es gibt gar keine
bessere chance zur profilierung für eine
liberale partei mit
regierungsbeteiligung ist jetzt zu sagen
wir
wir tragen keine maßnahmen mit die nicht
durch eine akute notlage
gerechtfertigt sind wir halten uns
sozusagen an die an die vorgaben unseres
grundgesetzes hat ja gar nicht
beschreiben einfach eine standards wobei
dann schon sage ich also ich teile die
kritik in der sache total aber zum
stichwort grundgesetz würde ich jetzt
schon mal sagen auch aus der perspektive
als der für das verfassungsrecht
zuständig ist unter juristen seminar als
gegen punkte drohen
diese seiten wollten sich ein gelerntes
maßnahmen sind jetzt nicht zwingend
verfassungswidrig rechtlich sind sie
machbar aber und da will ich einstimmen
in die kritik die denke ist natürlich
schon eine falsche zu sagen mannschaft
freiheitsbeschränkungen auf vorrat es
gibt für diese eine aus meiner sicht
auch keinen grund sondern wer über die
beschränkung von freiheitsrechten
entscheidet ist denn da für demokratisch
legitimierte gesetzgeber die können kann
jederzeit wieder zusammenkommen und
deswegen finde ich auch wir brauchen
jetzt nicht dieses breite
instrumentarium sondern der bundestag
muss als selbstbewusstes parlament sagen
wir geben hier keine vorratsbeschlüsse
dafür dass die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dann für
sich entscheiden und ich will auch an
den begrifflichkeiten basismaßnahmen das
klingt ja so dass der staat überhaupt
ein bisschen was könne kontakt
beschränkung masken pflicht das sind ja
alles krasse frites beschränken haben
uns zwar dran gewöhnt und ich finde sie
sind ja auch an vielen stellen
gerechtfertigt aber da verliert der
staat in gewisser weise auch maß und
mitte wenn man das als basis maßnahmen
damit will man gar nicht wissen dass
dann halt mal sind vorlage uns war ich
fand sehr großartig ihr seid ja die
grünen die die hier sind ich die
angst du musst mich als gemeinsam also
die vier jugendorganisation von den
grünen der cdu die ansagen und der rbb
sind zusammen auf die straße gegangen
weiß dass ich vermisse philipp wann sind
denn mein junge politiker auf die straße
sein damit die kinder in der schule
keine masken tragen müssen und ich
glaube schon dass wenn in der politik
mal die stimmen dafür lauter werden
würde gibt jetzt auch noch weiß gar
nicht ob alle eltern dafür wären ehrlich
gesagt es ist auch unter eltern ganz
umstritten es gibt unter eltern wirklich
auch viele die dino kowitz strategie
fahren und die den wieder am liebsten es
hätte alles so ich glaube das ist nicht
so einfach durchzusetzen aus vorsicht
vor diesem diskurs glauben sie die
meinung hätten könnten dafür strafen
können dafür auf die straße gehen oder
sie könnten doch einfach im bundestag
sagen sie muss ja nicht so also können
sie ja auch ich muss aber sagen dass
masken thema auch in den schulen es ist
natürlich immer blöd wenn am ende nur
die schüler mit maske dasitzen und in
den clubs sitzen alle in der disco und
feiern hier sitzt ja und im auge weil
wir uns so wir sind arbeiten nämlich an
alle geimpft so nah und in kitas
beispielsweise ist das nicht der fall
wird erst am 5 also ich glaube ohne
maske
ich bin ja heute nach deutschland
geflogen im flughafen da haben alle
masken und diese maßnahmen gibt doch
jetzt keinerlei grundlage für irgendeine
maßnahme man wir haben diese mikro und
variante die wirksame ist dass eine
impfung was man müsste ihn wegen zu
lauter tja da müsstest du ja die leute
ermuntern
dass sie sich jetzt wieder ins leben
stürzen und das meine ich eben das ist
schon dass das macht die droge macht die
politik leidet an einer überdosis macht
und sie kommen jetzt von dieser droge
nicht mehr weg den epidemiologisch
wissenschaft nicht was man uns jetzt
jahrelang oder monatelang eingetrichtert
hat doch nichts mehr mit wissenschaft zu
tun
dass man masken tragen muss hat sich
noch nie was nicht wissenschaft zu tun
dass man in den schulen den kindern was
genannt so ich habe dass er bei uns
gesehen
und da muss man natürlich dann schon
schauen also da muss dann auch die
bürgerliche politik in deutschland muss
das natürlich aufarbeiten was die
regierung gemacht hat und warum man das
gemacht hat das ist also da braucht man
einen rechenschaftsbericht das muss man
halt klein analysieren weil hier sind
grenzen überschritten worden ist in
freiheitsrechte außer kraft gesetzt
wurden und eben die leute die politik
hat longo wied di lasso nicht los sie
ziehen sie einfach durch und ich teile
die enttäuschung auch aus schweizer
sicht über die fdp da bin ich froh bei
ihnen herr rosenfeld aber auch die cdu
tschuldigung naja alkohol habe ich nicht
im regal müssen die eier graf und wurde
dafür versteckt genehm ist doch mal
sagen so jetzt ist fertig ihr seid der
opposition ich will zur ehrenrettung der
fdp nur sagen wir sind die einzigen die
uns in der regierung vom sozialismus
beschützen
die cdu hätte die cdu muss ich die hosen
liebe philipp
rösler eine klare haltung wir haben eine
klare haltung auch adressiert zu diesem
thema basismaßnahmen und ich finde das
kann man jetzt nicht auf vorhalt
entscheiden sondern da muss das
parlament gefragt werden und am ende
klar parlament debattieren im plenum das
ist für manchen lässt sich das ist aber
die spielregeln der demokratie dass man
über freiheitsbeschränkungen immer
wieder neu entscheidet und ich solche
vorratsbeschlüsse